today's episode is a race against time
if we have any hope of bringing the
story of hi I'm Mary Mary to a happy
conclusion there's a mystery that needs
to be solved so today I'm equipping you
with everything you need to know and
from there well let's just try to solve
this thing so we can get this girl to
help that she needs before it's too late
hello Internet welcome to film theory
and the long-awaited part 2 in our
breakdown of the psychological horror
channel hi I'm Mary Mary if you missed
part 1 and I gotta be honest chances are
you did because it got flagged in
YouTube's systems as being too scary
trust me this is a series that you're
gonna want to catch up on it was a
really great episode of film theory
covering a fascinating series so do
yourself a favor and if you didn't watch
it the first time or you just need to
catch up
click the video right there up there in
the upper right hand corner of the
screen err I don't know there's some
fancy thing you can do on your TV to
pull up the recommended videos anyway
here's what the thumbnail looks like
watch it in the meantime let me give you
what you need to know to understand the
rest of today's theory hi I'm Mary Mary
is an independent YouTube channel that's
perhaps one of the scariest and most
disturbing that we've ever covered on
the channel other series like salad
fingers and don't hug me I'm scared are
certainly disturbing and shocking don't
get me wrong but ultimately they don't
feel real their shows their creepy wants
to be sure but there's a safety in the
fact that they're obviously a produced
series Mary Mary on the other hand is
raw it's unfiltered its aggressive its
unpredictable and as a result you just
exist in this pool of dread never
knowing when the next scare is gonna
happen making it something that is
terrifying to watch the plot goes like
this a young girl named Mary wakes up
one day in a copy of her parents home
that she can't escape from The Doors
won't open the windows won't break the
days are normal but at night she's
haunted by four entities the veiled lady
the beauty the shadow and the darkness
by tracking the entity's behavior and
locating flashing messages hidden
throughout the videos when they appear
he were able to conclude last episode
that the house is symbolic of Mary being
trapped in her own mind and that the
entities she's haunted by are the mental
illnesses that she has to struggle with
her mind is being tortured by the
monsters of anxiety regret depression
and self-loathing but the story doesn't
stop there you see there's a fifth and
final monster that we didn't cover in
that last episode one that doesn't roam
the
house one that lurks outside and may
just be the most sinister and most
dangerous monster haunting Mary of them
all and that's the one that we have to
explore today that's the one that we
have to uncover the truth of if we have
any hope of helping Mary come to a
positive conclusion in the series
because yes this is a series that we can
affect change in but in order to do that
we have to first reveal the fifth and
final evil of hi I'm Mary Mary so Mary
is trapped in this house right every
night having to deal with these demons
harassing her but then in episode 8
discovery something changes while being
chased through the house by the veiled
lady she throws open a door only to
discover that she's now outside swimming
as the video's description says I found
my garden the next episode outside
inside shows us that garden what you got
to say looks more like a forest really
but whatever she can call it whatever
she wants Mary feels safe here at peace
as the video says she could stay here
for hours by the end of the episode
she's booted out of the garden back into
the horrors of her daily life but
determined to find a way to get herself
back in eventually through some
unexplained means she does find her way
back and as we see in check-in she stays
there almost every night preferring it
to reality but not even the garden is
safe from intruders as we see in the
episode titled intruder the garden is
home to a fifth entity the woman in
white mysterious figure who hides her
face and can only mouth words to Mary a
figure who seems to be telling Mary to
leave the garden and that's what we're
here to discuss today is the woman in
white just a malicious entity this one
disguising herself in a color commonly
associated with purity and goodness with
the intention of getting married out of
her safe place and back into the hands
of the monsters at home or is the woman
in white the one and only force for good
trying to help Mary is the garden Mary's
only safe haven from the creatures that
torment are actually causing her more
harm I think the answer is yes I believe
that the garden is Mary's biggest and
most dangerous villain a representation
of Mary's turn to drug use as she
struggles with her mental illnesses and
not just any drug either
I think it's heroin in particular and
the woman in white is the one trying to
pull her away from that addiction so
let's break down all the clues that Mary
is left for us first let's just think
narrative lis about what it means for
Mary to be able to escape the house that
she
trapped in remember the house is a
symbol of Mary's mind for mental state
so leaving it is gonna be her entering
an altered mental state like a drug trip
it's also not uncommon for hard drug
users to describe their first experience
as euphoric giving them the exact thing
they needed to feel better about
whatever led them to the drug to begin
with and for Mary that's exactly what
we're seeing the Garden initially gives
her a sense of freedom and openness away
from all the monsters that have been
torturing her mind but just like with
drug use the garden quickly turns into
something much more sinister we see Mary
getting dependent on the garden as she
says in the opening of intruder I'm so
glad you're all my friends but no
offense I like the garden best she
openly tells us that she spends every
night in it that she no longer feels the
need to look for answers as to why she's
trapped in this house and slowly we
start to see the garden decay Mary's
trips to the garden are never quite as
enjoyable as that first time in fact as
the series goes on the garden begins to
change the Sun is rarely around rainy
cloudy weather begins to pervade the
place Mary begins to find abandoned
places and broken things sometimes the
garden is literally just water where she
starts to drown we're given a very
dissonant imagery of the garden being
torn apart with a different Mary
screaming at the spot where peaceful
Mary is resting almost as though reality
is trying to break through but can't the
garden even starts to make her
physically sick as at the end of the
video intruder the camera collapses and
we hear her vomiting just off-screen
these chaotic events are echoed in her
Twitter account with statements like my
garden naps don't seem to cut it anymore
sleeping in the garden doesn't feel
fulfilling and I think I might be
getting sick feel nauseous a lot but not
during the day usually when I enter the
garden this is all a direct parallel to
the five stages of drug addiction first
use regular use risky use dependence and
disorder Mary's first time is
practically an accident something that
she stumbles into as she runs from the
veiled lady and it's one that offers
temporary relief but once she starts
regularly going to the garden
become shorter they're less pleasant she
feels the need to go there more
frequently on a regular basis and just
like in drug addiction as the addiction
gets worse she loses interest in hobbies
and pushes away relationships in this
case her relationship with us the
audience she prefers the drugs she
prefers visiting the garden / spending
time with us the people who were helping
her get through the mental illnesses in
a healthy way even when the drugs start
making her sick she can't seem to stop
meanwhile back in the house when she
returns to it the monsters appear to be
getting worse the shadow representative
of her regret becomes so large that only
its hand can fit into the kitchen beauty
is shown towering over Mary as she lays
lifeless in her reflection even ripping
into Mary as we see in the final video
uploaded on to the channel so far the
veiled lady is physically harming her
and previously the only thing she did
according to Mary in her livestream was
say mean things so it's definitely
looking like with the discovery of the
garden the problems in her home again a
metaphor for her mind are worsening now
I mentioned earlier that I thought that
Mary's garden wasn't just any drug
addiction I thought it was heroin and
there are a handful of telltale signs
that this is most likely the case in the
video titled the last eight months her
hair begins to fall out or at least thin
to the point where it's easily torn off
her dental health also shows extreme
signs of damage pulling out a tooth
towards the latter half of that same
video both symptoms have been connected
to drug use and not just any drug use
apparently her hair loss is likely tied
to a condition known as telogen
effluvium where drug use shocks the
body's biological systems causing
certain hair follicles to prematurely
stop growing in essence killing them
resulting in the hair falling out three
months later same thing with the dental
issues in 2012 the Journal of American
Dental Association found that heroin and
methamphetamine users had higher rates
of tooth decay and oral issues as those
drugs did things like cause the roots of
the teeth to retract but our last and
most obvious clue as to what's going on
here is the repeated imagery of Mary
rubbing her arm starting and checking
and continuing all the way to where the
series is now we can see her repeatedly
checking her forearm this is her
checking for track marks areas of
discoloration along the veins that
become damaged due to injecting drugs
intravenously so Mary is clearly in a
bad state here already she's dealing
with mental issues
and now we see that she stumbled into
the world of drug addiction as well
which is only making her existing
problems works enter the mysterious
woman in white the fifth and final
entity one that appears inside Mary's
garden and one that Mary doesn't trust
but one that also appears to be trying
to help don't get me wrong she is
certainly a creepy figure I met a lot of
shy people in my time but even I'd freak
out a bit if anyone covered their face
and started shaking their eyeballs at me
and to make matters worse she doesn't
talk she just mouths her words which is
a bummer because both Mary and I suck at
lipreading oh my god I I can't lip-read
I'm sorry but unlike Mary I fortunately
have the power of rewind and I could
take this scene line by line and if Yuri
watch this clip way too many times and I
mean seriously way too many times this
video has like 79 thousand views and I
swear most of them are from me just
replaying this 20 second clip over and
over again you can actually start to
figure out what the woman in white is
trying to tell Mary knowing that the
garden is dangerous the fact that the
woman in white wants her to leave makes
it seem like Mary may have actually
finally found someone that's on her side
and that's not the only way that the
woman in white seems to be trying to
reach Mary Mary has a blog where she
posts things from around her house
including journal entries drawings and
corrupted pictures there's actually a
lot of really cool stuff hiding around
in this blog hidden in old entries just
stuff everywhere that really flushes out
the story but it's the website source
code that I want to call out right now
you see there's a hidden message that
you can piece together by checking the
source code of various posts across this
blog the message is really long so I'm
gonna condense it a little bit but it
essentially goes like this oh sorry
that's a different source code based
mystery franchise
[Music]
[Laughter]
slash register me whatsoever I'm not
even sure I've been physically fit into
the house they are making sure face this
for making you feel evil in the garden
you home I am just like the rest of but
I you can trust so since the woman in
wait is the only character that we've
seen in the garden we know that this
message is coming from her and with her
being just like the rest of them it
means that she too is a construct of
Mary's mind most likely her conscious
were her morality center the thing
that's trying to tell her right from
wrong anyway the message continues
terrible really i won
I am fight for control but I'm just too
weak to fight that's where you all come
I can't speak for Kentucky entirely from
wall there's a chance that she's like
listen I need you to help no that's not
me censoring anything the message just
cuts off right there in the source code
you know this because she tries again so
there it is the woman in white is a
force for good trying to get a message
across in addition to the white lady's
attempts at communication we also have
something new beginning to happen back
at Mary's home Mary begins to get phone
calls and the doorbell starts to ring
this is coming off as maddening to Mary
in the episodes but in truth it's her
mind twisting what is actually a good
sign yet another example of people from
the outside world trying to break
through trying to help her trying to
reach her and that is where the story is
left off the last video was seven months
ago and it shows Mary at her absolute
lowest but the thing is long gaps are
normal for the series and there is
clearly hope for Mary here the series
has obviously offered us as the viewers
a challenge via the woman in white
censored message it's hidden out there
for us to discover most likely hidden
via Mary's blog and the photos that it
contains which I'll link to down below
in the description so if we have any
hope of bringing this story to a happy
conclusion we need to find that message
and relay it back to Mary before it's
too late
before the series comes to a tragic
ending and that is unfortunately where
we have to leave things for now I'll
search for the message you search for
the message and hopefully we can solve
the mystery and finally get Mary the
help she needs and bring the story to
the happy conclusion that it deserves
before it's too late but hey that's just
a theory
Oh film theory and
[Music]